[Música]
[Aplausos]
permanece en la memoria de todos El
quinto elemento look de song Bruce
Willis
acompañados de un grupo de estrellas El
quinto elemento es una película icónica
[Música]
Y quién diseñó el vestuario nada menos
que Jean Paul gautia estamos en 1997 un
año en el que todavía se dibujaba con
lápiz y papel y también decisivo para la
historia de la moda O al menos Esa es la
tesis que defiende alexand Samson
curador de la última exposición del Palé
galiá museo de la moda de la ciudad de
París
1997 fue un año de Big Bang
un año de cambios de agitación
en tan solo 12 meses se celebraron casi
50 eventos y por acontecimientos me
refiero a colecciones
inauguraciones fallecimientos estrenos
de películas nuevos álbumes
que se convirtieron en Pilares
culturales a los que hoy aún nos
referimos
tiene algún ejemplo
presenta su colección
en la Que prendas elásticas se rellenan
con algodón y así cogen mucho volumen
que siguen siendo una obsesión para los
jóvenes creadores y es muy emocionante
saber que Martín margiela ha presentado
su colección stockman realizada sobre un
busto de sastrería y que convirtió el
proceso de la creación en el producto
final para cada uno de estos dos
creadores sus colecciones son
emblemáticas todos ellos se celebraron
en la primavera de 1997
y otro más en términos de diseño fuerte
otro ejemplo que puedo darles Stone Ford
en Gucci Tom Ford es un diseñador
estadounidense que fue nombrado por
Gucci en 1994 y revolucionó la casa de
moda italiana y lo hizo defendiendo su
propia estética a finales de los 90
porno chic para la primavera del 97
presentó una tanga tanto en cuerpos
masculinos como femeninos y aún hoy eso
es absolutamente la representación de su
estética
por lo tanto podría explicarse mejor
1997 porque son algunos años antes del
año 2000
en 1997 se produjeron algunos
acontecimientos similares en la historia
de la cultura general el éxito de la
clonación de la oveja Dolly que en 1997
prohibió la clonación humana en Francia
fue un motivo de Gran preocupación Es
evidente que los creadores son sensibles
a estas modificaciones corporales esta
idea del cuerpo biónico que también se
cuestiona a finales de los 90 con el
nacimiento de la Inteligencia artificial
O al menos el comienzo de su
popularización también se puede percibir
en el éxito cultural de las películas
del momento es la salida de Titanic la
publicación del primer libro de Harry
Potter la creación de Imac de Apple y es
cuando se funda Google hoy haciendo una
retrospectiva uno se da cuenta de que
todos estos son puntos de referencia
importantes y
ocurrieron en 1997
el uso de las nuevas tecnologías con el
Imac también permite a colette que está
a punto de abrir su tienda vender en
línea puede decirse que el 97 marca el
inicio de la venta en línea 1997 fue muy
importante porque marcó el momento en
que el mundo de la moda empezó a
aprovechar los poderes de esta nueva
oportunidad mediática internet recuerde
que en 1997 mucha gente y muchas marcas
desconfiaban mucho de internet porque
temían que los copiaran temían que el
hecho de que sus trabajos estuvieran por
todo internet supusiera un plagio
importante el comercio en línea aparece
se desarrolla a principios de los años
2000 a pesar de que ya existía en 1997
sobre todo en marcas como la redud y
lewish
la gran mayoría de los diseñadores
presentes en el palégale haa siguen
vivos y activos la cuestión ahora es
saber si desde 1997 sólo han trabajado
en sus logros o se han reinventado
sin embargo muchos creadores han
aumentado su creatividad desde 1997
Martín marguiela ha tomado rumbos
diferentes después de su colección
stockman ya fuera del oversize una
dirección de diseño más puro A mediados
de la década del 2000 joji yamamoto
también exploró diferentes caminos pero
siempre manteniendo esa especie de
visión nostálgica sigue haciendo ciertas
referencias al pasado que continúan
gustando mucho en la semana de la moda
cree que la nueva generación de
diseñadores que se presenta en París se
inspira en el año 1997
No creo Creo que no he sentido eso Si es
así no lo he visto La idea es que el año
de 1997 ofreció una gran variedad riedad
de puntos de referencia luego se trata
de que la gente los interprete
libremente Y de forma creativa todos y
cada uno de los diseñadores de hoy en
día tienen su propia visión para crear y
espero que pronto experimenten algo tan
trascendental como lo fue en 1997 para
la década de 1990
como el que fue estudiante de Jean Paul
Gutiérrez Víctor winsanto en su espíritu
la referencias a 1997 son evidentes
pasión tenacidad audacia